everyone's trying to deceive me and
they're doing different things in
different ways Brett is very good at
getting the kind of flow of the way that
he talks but there is some sounds that
sound like they might come from Down
Under Chloe has been the most reluctant
to speak today she also has some sounds
that tend towards American but then when
she's relaxed they sound a little more
English and then Hayley sounds very
natural and has the things kind of
flowing nicely but then there are a
couple of sounds that seem to be too
perfect almost that in real life
sometimes go away so my final decision
my person who I think is from England
is Chloe
[Music]
good job it's really hard to do a fake
accent of your own accent